As of this video, you can now support PolyMatter on Patreon. I'll tell you more at the end of this video, but for now, let's get to it.
Black Mirror is a TV show that’s completely
terrifying and also impossible to stop watching…
But it’s hard to describe why it’s so
good because it’s hard to define what it
even is.
Each episode is so independent, there aren’t
many common characteristics.
Except one.
Many people see the show as a critique of
technology.
And if that’s the case, it might be fun
to watch, but isn’t all that profound or
new.
Here’s an article making this very point:
“Black Mirror’s messages are usually pretty
simple.
Cell phones?
Bad.
Reality shows?
Social media?
Really bad.
Oh, sure, the setup and the execution of those
ideas is impressive, but the show’s primary
crutch is too often that it uses thought-provoking
and fascinating foundations in order to reach
the simplest, most alarmist possible conclusion
about a variety of technological innovations.”
I’ve also heard people describe the writing
as far too unrealistic.
It’s hard to imagine some of these worlds
ever coming true.
But both of these complaints miss the point.
Black Mirror isn’t actually about technology
- or the future.
But it’s not just that I enjoy the show,
I also think it’s more meaningful than many
give it credit for.
So what makes it so good, and what is it really
about?
The enemy always looks like technology because
it’s always present for those signature
jaw-dropping Black Mirror moments, but its
purpose is only to emphasize the characters
and their actions.
In White Christmas, Joe discovers Beth is
pregnant, the two get in a fight, and Beth
uses her digital eyepiece to permanently block
him in real life.
After years of desperation, Joe catches the
first glance of his daughter and it all becomes
clear: Beth used this feature to hide her
infidelity: it isn’t his child.
Horrifying as this technology is, it’s only
a vehicle for the thoughts and desires of
the characters themselves.
It isn’t responsible for her infidelity
or willingness to hide it for all those years.
This is a theme throughout the series: - The
people in White Bear want revenge, technology
is just along for the ride.
- And Nosedive and Fifteen Million Merits
have technology that ruins lives, but it only
works because of people’s willingness to
comply
Black Mirror uses technology as a writing
device, a tool to expose who we are in a way
that seems new - but isn’t really the focus.
Each story is really about problems we already
have, in a world without the episode’s technology.
And if you have any doubt about this, here’s
the creator of the show himself:
It’s a show about people, and how the traits
we all have can go very wrong, especially
when we’re enabled by the world around us.
Which I think explains why some episodes are
much better than others.
Here’s a poll of twenty thousand people’s
favorite episodes.
The higher rated episodes have well developed,
relatable characters, but less focus on sophisticated
technology.
And the futuristic worlds with more bland
characters rank lower.
I agree most episodes aren’t realistic - but
I consider it a feature not a bug.
A good dystopia is a warning, not a prediction.
1984 and Brave New World are overstated, and
that’s what makes them interesting.
The point isn’t to be accurate but to take
very real and important ideas and make them
entertaining enough that we’ll actually
pay attention.
And to test all of this, we can compare two
episodes:
Structurally, White Bear and Shut Up And Dance
are very similar:
We’re put in the shoes of a character who
we can relate to - they, like us, are confused
and worried.
And as they’re put in increasingly crazy
situations, we realize who our characters
really are.
We’re horrified, but we’re supposed to
be even more horrified by everyone else.
The excessive retribution and the off-putting
joy it gives them.
They end by showing the scale of the injustice
- how Victoria must endure her torture every
day, and how many people are being played
like Kenny.
So the stories are similar, but Shut Up and
Dance is ranked considerably higher - why
is that?
I think it supports the theory - Shut Up and
Dance has better characters, and that’s
what the show is really about.
Because the intended message is only communicated
if we feel bad for our character, which makes
us hate their antagonist.
We empathize with Victoria in White Bear because
we’re just as confused as she is.
But Shut Up and Dance has a longer exposition
- we really get to know Kenny before the adventure
begins - we learn who he is and how he lives.
So we’re more empathetic when he’s in
trouble, and more distressed when he’s exposed.
But none of this wastes any time - those early
scenes eventually come back to haunt us with
new meaning.
It also has more big reveals, it just keeps
hitting us on the head.
When they open the cake and we realize the
seriousness of the situation,
Then when we meet the real Kenny,
And after all that, when their secrets are
still released in one final, devastating,
“screw you”.
Which some people dislike - the troll face
can come across as a bit absurd.
I actually think it’s important for developing
that character.
It’s silly and childish - but it gives us
a sense of the person behind it.
Some young, reckless person who does this
for the thrill.
Completely unrestrained by the law or any
sense of human empathy.
Black Mirror is good because it’s incredibly
entertaining to watch a character be built
up and then come crashing down in an instant.
And also because those characters are us.
Behind every disaster is a perfectly familiar
human characteristic that you have too, just
waiting for the wrong situation to become
your downfall.
Hey there.
Making these videos is a lot of fun, but what’s
not fun is relying on an algorithm I can’t
understand to make money.
So I’m starting a Patreon.
Ideally, my real customer here is you - I
can make what you, not the algorithm, wants.
And the economics are great - the marginal
cost can be very small from you, but together
very big for me.
So any amount will give you early access to
videos, a Discord discussion following each
video, and wallpapers for your devices.
A bit more will give you access to Behind-The-Scenes
for each video, so you can learn how I make
these videos and how you can make your own.
And at least for now, I’ll make you a custom
graphic of your choosing - a profile icon,
banner, logo, or something else.
There’s absolutely no obligation, and all
of my main videos will remain free on this
channel.
Thank you so much, and for those of you who
go support the channel, I’ll see you in
the Discord.